c'est un benyamin nétanyahou satisfait
qui accueille le 9 décembre dernier à
l'aéroport ben gourion de tel aviv
les premiers vaccins du partenariat
américano allemand pfizer du high-tech
c'est un jour de célébration pour israël
nous voyons la fin nous devons encore
observer des mesures les masques le
lavage des mains la distanciation
sociale mais la fin de la pandémie est
en vue et ce qui est important pour moi
c'est que les citoyens israéliens se
fassent vacciner je crois en ce vaccin
l'état hébreu qui travaille en parallèle
sur son propre vaccin avait acheté en
novembre 8 millions de doses à pfizer
mais aussi 6 millions laboratoire modern
art soit un total de 14 millions de
vaccins pouvant protéger à terme les
sept des neuf millions d'israéliens la
vaccination impliquant deux doses à
trois semaines d'intervalle
israël n'a en revanche pas communiqué
s'il comptait fournir des vaccins en
cisjordanie occupée et dans la bande de
gaza confrontés une récente
recrudescence du nombre de cas
l'arrivée du pacs en palestine dépend de
plusieurs facteurs les plus importants
sont la disponibilité et la possibilité
de le transporter en palestine avec tout
le processus et des contraintes liées au
transport du vaccin mais en palestine
malheureusement nous n'avons pas le
contrôle sur nos postes frontaliers
parce que nous sommes un état sous
occupation et donc ces questions sont au
delà de notre volonté car les doses du
vaccin pfizer bio intech nécessite des
conditions bien particulières en termes
de stockage et de transport et la
palestine ne dispose que d'un seul
réfrigérateurs capables de maintenir une
température de moins en moins 70 degrés
il faudrait donc investir chose
impossible pour l'autorité palestinienne
confronté à une grave crise financière
les palestiniens ont donc déposé une
demande dans le cadre de l'initiative
kovacs un programme soutenu
conjointement par l' oms et
l'organisation internationale de
vaccination gavi dont l'objectif est de
fournir au moins 2 milliards de doses
d'ici fin 2021 pour vacciner 20% des
personnes les plus vulnérables des pays
pauvres
les palestiniens sont donc dans la tente
jusqu'à présent nous ne pouvons pas dire
que le vaccin arrivera dans une semaine
dix jours de semaine ou un mois
parce que l'om est c'est l'alliance gavi
on dit que ces deux seront distribués en
mais nous espérons obtenir le vaccin dès
que possible
mais pour réussir son objectif kovacs
dit avoir besoin de plus de 4 milliards
d'euros
en plus d 1 milliard 700 millions déjà
collectés selon une étude de johns
hopkins bloomberg school of public
health
une personne sur quatre n'aura pas accès
au vaccin contre le rotavirus avant -